the new trailer for frozen to left us
totally shook and it sure looks like
Elsa isn't the only one with magical
abilities stay tuned to find out whether
or not Anna has powers of her own
sometimes I really don't like you the
new trailer when Disney dropped the new
trailer for frozen - the world was
shocked
the sequel looks like it's going to be
action-packed it also looks a lot darker
than the first movie let's take a closer
look the trailer opens on the beach at
the edge of the sea but this is no calm
day at the beach it's dark and it looks
like a storm is on its way the waves are
crashing like crazy Elsa is standing at
the edge of the water looking determined
she ties her hair back like she's ready
to fight then she takes off running into
the sea she runs and uses her powers to
make it further and further out into the
ocean she's trying to use her magic to
conquer the sea we just loved Elsa's
determination she turns a giant wave
into a block of ice it collapses on top
of her and she falls into the water then
the trailer switches gears next we see
anna she rushes out onto her balcony
with a terrified look on her face there
are these ice diamonds floating in the
air they all have different symbols on
them but we'll get to those later next
we see Kristoff he looks determined as
he rides on spins back
Sven is running along with a whole herd
of reindeer he almost looks like they're
running into a battle we go back to Anna
she's alone and cold in the dead of
night she climbs on top of a giant cliff
all by herself she runs to the edge and
jumps off then we see Elsa and Olaf
there standing in a giant heart-shaped
ring of purple fire Elsa is using her
magic to fight it off why is it a heart
instead of a circle what does it mean we
later see Anna Elsa Olaf and Kristoff
and Sven looking out over a valley it's
hard to tell if they're looking at
arendelle or a brand-new landscape what
we do know though is that it's
definitely autumn the screen cuts to
black and in orange leaf swirls around
the screen then we see Anna Elsa and
Kristoff walking through a dark forest
they look scared
all of a sudden Anna turns around takes
Kristoff Sword and swings it this
trailer was packed with so much
information in similar
and there wasn't even any talking there
is a lot of magic in the new movie and
it's not just Elsa's icy powers some
frozen fans are convinced Anna has
powers of her own so let's explore the
possibility the first movie you might
think we're crazy when we say that the
first movie proves anna has powers but
hold on to your seats we're going to
prove it to you first of all we know
that Elsa was born with powers she
wasn't cursed or anything like that
after Elsa accidentally hit Anna with a
blast of ice their parents took them to
see the magical trolls these trolls are
famous for being crystal wielding
healers and later we find out that red
crystals are infused with fiery magic
that's important to this theory King
Gagner tells grandpappy that Elsa was
born with her abilities something to
keep note of is that the king and queen
of arendelle aren't fazed by Elsa's
powers in fact they seem to know a lot
about them they even have magic themed
books in their library which is what led
them to the trolls in the first place so
what we're trying to say is that magical
humans aren't unheard of so why was Elsa
born with magic and not Anna and who
says she wasn't they are sisters after
all siblings share DNA among many other
things it's definitely possible that
Anna also is gifted Anna was super young
when Elsa struck her in the head with
ice to stop something like this from
ever happening again
grandpappy removed all of on his
memories of magic the fans seemed to
think that his actions also prevented
Anna from realizing that she had powers
of her own this isn't the only evidence
from the movie though honest spent her
early life in complete solitude she was
made to remain within the castles walls
which was a total bore yet she somehow
has all these crazy survival skills she
goes out to look for Elsa and she
doesn't even dress appropriately
she's cold but she doesn't freeze to
death she can also fight she saves
Kristoff from the wolves and what does
she use fire she launches burning stuff
at the wolves and somehow she doesn't
get burned did you notice that in the
first movie that's more than just an
adrenaline rush she's also super strong
but we're not referring to emotional
strength although she has that too she
hits a wolf with a guitar
hard enough to send him flying and when
she fights off marshmallow the snow
monster she flings a whole tree at him
she cuts through a strong rope like it's
nothing and she punches Hans so hard he
falls into the water how could a girl
like Anna do that if she didn't have
powers we can also see some Hansen on
his wardrobe she is fiery red hair and
green eyes
she wears green all the time and her
clothes have fully bloomed flowers all
over them
her clothes are usually decked out in
what we would refer to as summer couture
whereas Elsa is traditionally seen
wearing I see colors and blue hues anna
is often captured in summary lights so
we're led to believe that she possesses
fiery powers which is the exact opposite
of what her sister is known for the four
seasons the summer and winter symbols
are very important clues we know that
summer and winter are opposites heat
melts snow after all but don't go
telling olaf that i'm guessing you don't
have much experience with heat nope in
one of her videos alice bunny takes a
long detailed look at the symbolism of
the seasons and she's super smart about
all of this Josh GAD who voices Olaf
posted a photo of snowflakes on its
social media but when you take a closer
look it's not just a snowflake first of
all it has too many points and secondly
the snowflake planes have all these
symbols on them some people think those
symbols are Old Norse runes that was the
written language used by Vikings they're
from the same area as the kingdom of
arendelle
but these symbols are definitely not
runes and Alice Bunny thinks they
symbolize the Four Seasons one of them
looks like a diamond or a crystal this
means winter the next one looks like a
leaf falling to the ground which could
be autumn across from the winter symbol
is what looks like the Sun over the
horizon this represents summer the last
one looks like a flower flowers bloom in
spring
hey Disney that is pretty sneaky we also
know that the new movie takes place in
autumn the last one started in the
spring but Elsa turned arendelle into
winter and then there's the Disney short
frozen flu it's all about Ana's birthday
we know that Ana's birthday is in the
summer it's bright and there is a lot
sunshine there are flowers everywhere
and these only bloom in the middle of
summer plus we already talked about on
an else's appearance these sisters
represent opposing seasons which is
definitely symbolic firepower also
represents winter and has ice powers so
if Anna represents summer
what would her power be well the answer
is in the opposites
let's go back to the trolls the trolls
are made of stone and they have all
sorts of magical abilities a lot of
magic mythology is based on the ideas of
four elements one of the elements is
earth which the trolls themselves
definitely represent earth is usually
represented by green and some of the
trolls are seen wearing green crystals
another element is water and this is
where Elsa's powers come from she wears
a lot of Blues and oddly enough the
trolls also have blue crystals the third
element is air which is often
represented by yellow and the fourth
element is fire which is depicted by the
color red
when Kristoff brings Anna to the trolls
a little troll shows off her red crystal
some people add in a fifth element which
they refer to as the heart the director
of frozen chris buck has mentioned this
before he said after the first movie
that Ana's real power is love and it is
love that saves the day so does that
mean that anna has two sources of magic
that could make her even stronger than
Elsa why else do we think that anna has
the powers of fire in love well
there's proof in the trailer for frozen
- we see Elsa and Olaf fighting off fire
this fire is purple so it looks pretty
magical but this fire is in the shape of
a heart it's a symbol of love it's
possible that this fiery heart derives
from Anna so why're Elsa and Olaf in
danger keep watching to find out honest
new powers we already talked about why
on it doesn't show her fire powers in
the first movie however she does have
some powerful traits that make us
believe her magic is still there but the
memory of magic was removed from her as
a child
grandpappy did that to protect her so
honest spends most of her life not
knowing about her magic I also grew up
with magic and she had a good grasp over
it as a kid but honor didn't get the
chance to learn about her
well she's an adult now and she's got to
learn to control it as a kid Elsa was
still learning to master her intense
powers that's how she hurt honor if
honest learning about her powers she's
probably going to have trouble
controlling them and that is probably
why a ring of fire is around Elsa and
Olaf of course maybe it was intentional
on oculd have used her magic to keep
also from coming after her we know from
the trailer that at some point in the
movie Anna goes off by herself she could
have trapped Elsa so she had time to get
away the heart might be a reminder that
she still loves her sister and Anna
notes that fire isn't actually a danger
to Elsa but why would Anna want to go
off on her own we still have so many
questions
our Ana's power is going to cause an
accidental emergency like Elsa's did and
frozen fire can definitely cause some
serious issues some people believe that
Anna might become an accidental villain
but we aren't so sure about that the new
villain there are a lot of theories
buzzing around the internet about who
the new villain could be some people
think that the trolls are actually the
bad guys it wouldn't be the first time
that Disney let us think that a bad
character was actually a good guy they
they even did that in the first frozen
movie unsure seemed like a good guy at
first but he turned out to be the worst
speaking of Hans lots of people think
he'll be back there have been theories
about Hans since before frozen 2 was
even announced some people think he
might even have powers like Elsa because
he's often seen wearing gloves there
could also be a new villain in the
trailer we see a blond haired voice
soaring through a pile of leaves and it
sure seems like autumn is important in
the new movie maybe the new villain has
the ability to control the autumn season
that power might be related to wind
which is one of the four elements
whoever the new villain is we can't wait
to see them in action
frozen 2 comes out in November 2019
don't be shy tell us your frozen two
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching don't forget to hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date with
the latest Disney news we'll catch you
next time
[Music]